Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Elkhound .
What?
I'm Link.
This week on the round
table, a dim lighting
with, on it.
On that.
We're throwing down.
On.
The story.
Is that a DJ pun?
Yep, yep, yep.
I speak differently.
On the table?
I speak differently as a DJ.
This week we're throwing
down the knowledge,
tossing down the knowledge.
I am regaling the development,
the highs, and lemme tell you
the lows, of becoming a DJ
and developing and revealing my persona.
Are you sure you don't wanna
just make this into a book?
Like right now, this is your last chance
'cause we have things.
"The Highs and Lows of Elkhound ?"
If you think about the
hierarchy or the way
that we do our lives.
Yeah.
We've got stories that begin and then stop
because they need to be
reserved for the podcast,
but we might be in a, stories
that need to be reserved
for your memoir and so, you know.
Yeah, but I need to be recording those.
I would do, I'm gonna
do it on this podcast.
You can do both of 'em.
You think you can do that?
Oh yeah, I can do both.
Okay.
All right.
This could be in the book.
I, it's like I can have
two DJ names that are one.
I can do both.
Right, it's true.
So.
Is this Elkhound speaking
now or Snugglebaby?
This is Elkhound speaking to you.
Okay.
All right, so when you say it,
you just say it like that, Elkhound .
You don't say Elkhound, .
I have not put the pause, no.
Okay.
But I'm glad you're so
interested in the details,
'cause I'm gonna have
to get into all those.
I, yeah, a lot of people are asking
how I came up with the name.
You know, there's the whole
look, my get up that I debuted
at Mythicon on the last
night at the dance party,
and I'm really curious, as I
talked to you about last week,
of just like, we haven't talked about
your perspective on all of it.
There was a lot of it
that I was developing
independently and whew, you know.
It, there's also, there's
another layer to this,
which is just like the creative journey
of developing something
new that in some ways,
in many ways, maybe in all
the ways you experienced
with James and the Shame
that I think is kind of a,
I'll call it a B story here today.
So if you don't like DJing,
if you're not into
persona development and.
Who, what?
I mean.
Who isn't?
I don't know what your problem is.
I mean DJing, but if you're
not into persona development.
Right, then who are you?
Is there anyone who is ever
like on a dating profile,
specifically not into persona development?
Not anyone I've dated.
Conceptually.
Not anyone I've swiped in the direction
that means I am interested.
I don't know which direction that is.
Yeah, never, I never swiped either way.
But yeah, there's that B story of
stepping outta your comfort
zone, taking a creative risk,
and then seeing what happens.
Definitely, my DJ launch
experience and some of the stuff
I'll tell you about afterward,
it's, it definitely is,
has been uncomfortable
at times and I think
it's been very good.
It's been very edifying.
You know, I'm just trying
to take in all parts
of this experience and just
milk the teat for all it's worth.
Just, I'm milking the teat, DJ teat dry
and I'm, it turns out
I'm rapidly experiencing
just a full range of emotions.
Oh wow.
Associated with it, so that's kind of
what's going on here too.
Should we just get into it?
I mean, why am I calling myself as a DJ
Elkhound , but do not
put DJ in front of it
and do put.
Yeah, people have been
trying to do that.
Do, don't do that, and do put
Snugglebaby in parentheses.
Elkhound, one word, space,
open parentheses, parenthesis?
Parenthesis.
One parenthesis.
Yeah, Jenna and I worked on this.
Snugglebaby, all one
word, closed parenthesis.
The only thing I'll say
at this moment is that
I feel like I've had some
independent parallel experiences
that will inform my, are
informing my perspective
as we get to those places where you tell
those parts of the story,
but I mean, I feel like
just last night, and I'll
keep this very brief,
I had an experience, a
DJ witnessing experience,
not like I tried to
share the Lord with a DJ.
You witnessed a DJ.
I witnessed a DJ.
Okay.
You know.
One of my kind.
I got to go to the Orville Peck concert,
and Orville invited me to
the, this is his final.
Orville invited me.
You know, Orville.
This was the final show
of the tour in LA, invited
me to the after party
and Jessie and I went and we
showed up and there was a DJ.
It was like kind of a house
that's also a club in Hollywood,
and there was a woman who was DJing and.
Women can DJ, yes.
Keeping it pretty, I
wasn't saying anything.
I was just specifying so,
that felt inappropriate,
but she was kind of, just kind
of keeping it kind of chill,
and then a dude came in
and Jessie leans over to me
and she's like, why is
that guy like, leaning in
and seeming to begin to kind of like
intrude on this woman's DJ space?
Oh.
And I looked up and I
said, because that's Diplo.
So at that point.
Well I be dag.
I, which I would say.
We're cut from the same ilk,
me and Diplo.
So as a DJ,
this guy's what top, you
know, well he's in the top,
he's cream of the crop DJ, right?
Yeah.
So I was like, having witnessed the birth
of Elkhound .
Yeah.
And his first adventure, you know,
I haven't really watched a DJ before
until I watched Elkhound , and so then,
so now I've got a parallel
experience to sort of,
when we get to that, I'll
just give you some of my notes
that I was able to take.
Yeah, I definitely want
to be compared to Diplo at
this point in my career.
Like, that is exactly.
It was just an interesting juxtaposition.
Right, but that's totally fair.
I feel like the universe is giving me
a vantage point.
I don't know
what you're saying.
No, I'm saying that.
Don't clarify.
I'm saying anything I
learn about DJing is,
now I have a vessel that I can send it to.
Okay, good.
Okay.
If I learn something about
DJing in my everyday life,
I give it to Elkhound .
That's my mission.
I did.
I did tell Diplo that if he
wants to show up at any of
my sets, he can lean in and
give a little scritchy scratch.
He will, he'll lean in and eventually
he'll take over completely.
What does a DJ name his child?
This is a joke that Lando
told me this morning,
'cause he now talks to
me as if I'm Elkhound .
D Junior?
No, DJ names his child Eric.
Oh, that's much better.
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah.
What does a DJ order at
an Italian restaurant?
Spaghetti.
No.
Marinara, marinara.
Okay, yeah.
Marinara.
Some words work better than others.
Yeah.
Eric, marinara.
Just marinara, that's an odd order.
Just saying.
I mean.
Let's, okay, so how did
I come up with the name?
Well, you know, you were encouraging me.
You were like, I, you, I know you're,
you said you're gonna do this DJ set.
You need to go, like, you
need to go all the way.
Like, don't just half-ass it.
Like, let's, you need
to make this a moment.
You know, to your credit,
you gave me the encouragement
I needed at just the right time.
Like a month ahead of Mythicon, probably.
I had been, I'd been
thinking about my set.
I'd been working on it.
I'll talk about that a little bit,
but, well, I'll just say that like,
I was pretty nervous about
it and I, so I didn't,
at the point that we
had that conversation,
I didn't have a lot of confidence.
Now I'm implying I got a
lot of confidence later.
Maybe I did, I don't know,
and you had that conversation with me
and I was talking about how I'm practicing
and how I'm kind of nervous about it,
and that's when you gave
me the input of like,
well you need to make it a moment.
It's the end of Mythicon.
You need to make a big reveal about,
I mean, you're saying what your name is,
but you need to have a
look to go along with it,
and I was like, I had thought
about it, but I just wasn't,
I don't know, I think I
was so nervous about it
that I was scared that if I
fully committed in my mind
to making it a thing, especially publicly,
that like, people could
take pictures of me
and it would be worth sharing,
because of the way.
Oh, they did.
I looked and that the, that I would be
building it up too much, that it,
I'm just starting out DJing and
it would seem like I thought
I was the shit when really I'm just
a fledgling DJ person, you know?
And so I was wrestling with that,
but I was like, you know what?
He's right.
I gotta go for it, and
so I started throwing out
some of my thoughts, which were,
yeah, I do need to have a get up.
My, but I don't wanna wear a helmet.
You know, all of these DJs wear helmets.
Yeah.
The Daft Punk's of the world,
the Deadmau5's of the world,
the Marshmello's, and et cetera.
I don't wanna cover this face
because anybody who want,
they wanna know it's
me, any Mythical Beast
who's showing up at this particular show.
Right.
And I was thinking more about
the first show than like,
like my long career
into the distant future
as a DJ, which may happen.
Hopefully it will.
So I was like, I don't wanna come.
People wanna, you know,
people wanna see my face
'cause they wanna, they came to see me DJ.
Yeah.
And I also don't want
to mess with my hair.
You know, my hair is, it's
attached to my face at the top
and it's something, I really
like my hair, you know.
It's part of my signature.
Right.
So then I'm like, well,
I, what could I do?
And then like, I was thinking antlers.
I think you were part
of this conversation.
You might have thrown out antlers too,
but I was definitely thinking that.
I was like, yes, it's a Mythical tie-in,
but like, not, like the
antlers need to be big.
So then it was, it got
to elk pretty quick.
Well, there was like a moose thought,
and then it was like, you know what,
moose antlers are, like,
they're real like, big hands.
Satellite dishes almost.
Yeah, they're like satellite dishes.
That could definitely work.
It's definitely big, and I
was like, but I knew that elk
have these magnificent antlers
that are more deer-like
that seem pretty cool.
So I'm like, I bet you I
could do something like that,
and then instead of it attaching
to my head, I was like.
'Cause that would be uncomfortable.
What if there was some sort
of like, shoulder mount
that then the antlers would come up
and they would be behind my head?
Came up with all this before
really coming up with a
DJ name, the look and then
that's what led to, all right, elk.
You know, we're talking about elk antlers,
and then I remembered my mom had a dog
that was a Norwegian elkhound.
Actually it was before
I was born when my mom
and dad were together,
they had a dog that was
a Norwegian elkhound named Sam.
It's, a Norwegian elkhound
is a beautiful dog
that according to some
tweets, after I put my moniker
out there, people were
telling me, like, these dogs,
I guess they herd elk and they will run
between the legs of galloping elk.
Of course my mom and dad, my
dad was a farmer at the time
and my mom worked at
like, a medical facility
and there were no elk
anywhere in the region.
That dog was very disappointed.
But the dog would run all over the farm
and just come back at the end of the day.
It was just like, it,
I've, I have pictures.
What happened to this dog and the divorce?
I, you know what, I need to ask Mom.
They set it free?
I think the dog stayed on the farm.
I can't quite remember, but
the dog was special to Mom
and beautiful, like black and
white fur, kind of husky-like.
So I was like Elkhound,
I like that name for a DJ
better than just like elk.
That just seems like, that's just a word,
and then I'm like, so Elkhound.
Yeah, that's good, that's it.
That could be it.
But that's not enough.
And then I'm like.
I need four more syllables.
That's not enough.
It wasn't enough, 'cause
then I was concerned
that if I call myself Elkhound,
then people might think
that that's just cool.
That's a cool name for a DJ.
Mm.
That DJ better be good,
is kind of what I was
thinking at the time,
but really just, that
DJ, that's a cool name.
Maybe it sounds like this
person who calls himself
that is taking himself too seriously.
I wanna add something to it
that presents a different side,
'cause Elkhound is like, it's
Elkhound, it's percussive.
It could almost be abrasive.
It could almost be kind
of emphatic in your face,
like that's what that
word feels like, Elkhound.
It's like, it hits hard.
So then I want something
to soften the edges.
I want something that
that gives a different,
but complementary energy,
and I also want something
that when people have to say
it, 'cause when you come up
with a name, you basically,
there's a lot of power in a name.
You know, when people
name kids, happens a lot.
Every time someone has
one, they seem to name it.
That's a lot of power.
It's becoming less common though.
You're, becoming less common, you.
Names.
You're dictating what will
flow from the lips of everyone
that interacts with this
person, and so it's wielding
some sort of power over them.
I recognized that and I wanted
to use that power for smiles.
So I decided that I wanted
to add, the first thing
that came to my mind when I
put all this criteria together.
Oh, that was the first one.
Was Snugglebaby, because, and
I liked the idea of people
having to call me
Snugglebaby and try to do it
with a straight face.
It just seemed very Link to do this,
and like, unexpected.
Well, that's for sure.
I think we're all in agreement on that.
And then when you put that together,
it's a combination of
words that doesn't exist.
So when you're talking about
buying a website domain
or like trying to get the
TikTok moniker, what is it,
whatever it's called, the
username on Twitter and Instagram.
I, Twitter and Instagram.
I don't know if you can fit Elkhound.
It's ElkhoundSnug.
Okay, yeah.
But on TikTok, it's Elkhound Snugglebaby.
But are you gonna actually use those?
I don't know yet.
Use those.
Feel free to follow 'em.
'Cause I created them
for James and the Shame
and then I was like, am I gonna do?
I just wanna own em,
which I do.
Yeah, having them parked
is a good idea.
So it's like, because Elkhound,
that's already been taken.
It's a freaking dog.
I could have.
It's just a dog's account.
I could've just been Snugglebaby.
I think I did find one account that was a,
like, a foot fetish account
that nobody followed,
and I'm like.
That's called Snugglebaby?
Yeah.
Thank you for pointing that out.
Well if you search for it, if you find
the foot fetish
Snugglebaby, that's not me,
but, and I kind of, I was
like, I feel good about this,
and then I believe you were
the first person I told
'cause weren't we at the
Creative house when I told you,
because you were the one who was like,
well you gotta put Snugglebaby
in parentheses, and I'm like.
And I stand by saying this.
I'm like, what?
I'm like, why do I have
to put it in parentheses?
It's like.
But you can't, but you agreed.
The first thing that I liked
about the suggestion was
it's kind of like, if
you're a true hip hop fan,
you know that MF DOOM has to always
be presented in all caps, and
so I like that kind of test
and that's why I had to
like, go on record on Twitter
and like be very adamant
about how it was spelled
because hey, there it is.
If you know, you know.
I'm not gonna keep, and I reiterated
at the beginning of
this, but you know what.
I'm not gonna do that anymore.
At one point I was thinking
I was never going to write it
at all and people were
just gonna have to say
open parenthesis, closed
parenthesis, but that was stupid,
but I did like that
idea of it being like a,
if you know, you know, and
how to spell it.
But you also seem to.
And it was just weird.
But you also seem to embrace the fact
because basically what I,
the reason I suggested that
is because when you described
it and 'cause you basically,
you gave your reasoning
that you just gave me,
which is like.
Yeah.
I'm, there's Elkhound, but,
and that might just be cool,
all exactly what you
just said, and so to me
it kind of sounded like there
is this sort of exterior shell
that people may interact
with, which is Elkhound,
and then there is this,
if you know, you know,
the sort of the interior Snugglebaby,
and it's like, for, because for me.
Oh.
This gives you this flexibility.
So you're saying that the
parentheses become like a womb.
I wasn't suggesting or picturing a womb.
You can do that if you want.
All I'm saying is that because
you seem to embrace this,
I'm not gonna give it
away 'cause I wanna hear
what your process was,
even during your set.
Yeah, well that came to light later.
So it had ripple effect.
Which I think that was,
I thought that was a really
good application of it because.
Yeah.
In my mind, it could
be like, at this party
Elkhound's showing up
and that's all you got.
To me it was like, it's two people in one.
One's a little bit more
if you know, you know,
but it just gives you this flexibility
and also, yeah, it's
kind of weird and funny.
I definitely have developed
it as more of like
a Jekyll and Hyde, two
sides of a coin persona.
Two for the price of
one birds in the hand.
And maybe at some point as you evolve,
'cause you are an animal and
animals undergo evolution
and so do people 'cause
people are animals,
you could actually
update your suit so that
when you, there's
actually a transformation
that takes place during a show.
I mean it's just like, I just feel like
there's so many possibilities.
There's so many possibilities.
Yeah.
It kind of hinges on becoming a good DJ.
That is probably paramount, yeah.
Which I am excited about,
but I will tell you it ain't easy.
One, just some words about my costume.
Elise, who's a friend of Mark Byers,
who produced a lot of our music,
actually Mike Paisley introduced me to her
because he was so busy and
Jesse was so busy building
all the stuff from Mythicon
that they didn't have
any capacity to build my DJ outfit.
So I got Elise in on the action.
So she designed it for me.
We went with like a Viking
motif that was like a rugged,
it's less of, I'm an
animal and more of like,
I'm, it's kind of like.
You killed an animal.
Viking garb type thing with the way
the stuff that's on the,
wrapped around the antlers.
There's like some flare on
it and then there's like,
a shoulder draped cape, like, a fur drape,
and if you think that my
shoulders look big under there,
it's not because I'm
wearing shoulder pads,
it's just 'cause I'm that buff.
Hmm.
And there are shoulder pads under there.
Oh okay.
Thanks for clarifying.
Whoo that got kind of,
it gets kind of hot.
So I had to wear tank top and shorts.
I noticed.
So that, I ended my
ensemble by wearing like,
some small corduroy shorts and then
tennis shoes and crew socks.
So it's kind of daddish
on the bottom.
Yeah, I got that.
I had that vantage point.
I was behind you.
Yeah, you gotta be
behind the deck for that.
Wanna take a quick just second
just to acknowledge that
when this comes out it's
freaking Cyber Monday tomorrow,
and starting right now.
And so all those sales.
There's so many sales happening.
We've had over at mythical.com
and also mythicalsociety.com, okay.
These are some of the deals
that started on Friday
and then continue through tomorrow
if you're watching this as it comes out.
20% off sitewide.
40% off Sike products.
40% off Sike.
And we've also got a new
product, GMM ornaments.
You should get those soon
if you wanna get those.
We had ornaments last year that were us.
This year, we got some amazing
new Mythical ornaments.
Check it out.
Mythicalsociety.com.
We've got 20% off monthly first
and second degree memberships,
30% off monthly third degree memberships.
So mythical.com, mythical.com,
mythicalsociety.com, incredible deals.
There you go.
Get it while they last.
Cyber Monday.
I, DJing really suits me.
I think I've told you this before,
I might have talked about
it on the podcast, but like,
I bought a deck, like over
the pandemic I had signed up
for Masterclass just so I could take
Questlove's Masterclass on DJing,
which turned out to not be that technical,
but it was more like an overview.
So it was like a really cool primer
to just start to understand
the in and outs of it.
Spiritual DJing.
Yeah, and you know, I think,
yeah, that happened before I
was like, stepped into the role
of DJing the Christmas in
July party here at Mythical,
but I only had my lap, I only had Spotify.
I didn't have any real
means to actually DJ
and I learned so many things
about it that I told you about
that necessitated me buying a DJ deck.
Like, I bought a used one off eBay.
So that, it's interesting this,
my psychology along the way.
It's good for me to notice
this in myself because I don't,
it's something to overcome.
If someone's trying something
creative kind of like me,
but like, I would rationalize things like,
I'm not gonna buy a deck new
because then I'll feel bad
when I don't follow through with this.
So I'm gonna buy a used one
off eBay so I won't feel
as bad if I walk away from this.
It's such an, you know, it was
like I was giving myself outs
in full instead of like
saying, you know what?
I think I could be really into this.
I'm going to go for it.
At so many.
Buy something so new and expensive
that you'll feel guilty if you stop.
That's what I would've done.
You know, you're like.
Right.
Like guilt yourself into not stopping.
I kind of had this predisposition,
oh this probably won't turn into anything.
I'm gonna encounter something
that's gonna be the reason
that like, I just never
follow through with it,
and that's why I like when I,
even when I was doing Mythicon,
I was like, I'm not gonna
make a big deal out of this.
You know, it's not a healthy instinct.
I think it's something
that I've had to overcome,
and that's why I just, I'm going back
trying to acknowledge it
'cause I'm learning from it,
but I just really started
getting into, I love music,
I love listening to music.
Like especially over the
pandemic, I got really into it.
So then, like being able to
manipulate music and turn knobs,
there's like a, the editor
in me and I'm talking like,
video editor in me that
I don't do anymore,
it's like that really came
to, that came back to me
like using the deck.
It's just a lot of fun.
And you like making playlists
for certain, to set vibes.
I love making playlists.
Yeah, yeah, and greatest
compliment you can give me is,
can I have the playlist you were playing?
So as I started getting ready
for Mythicon, I was like,
I kept, I just didn't, there's two things.
It's like working on what
songs you're gonna play
and then working on the skills
of a DJ to be able to like,
operate the deck and
transition between songs
and put things in an order,
kind of make it seamless,
and once you start watching tutorials
and reading about stuff,
it gets overwhelming
really quickly, and at that
point, Ben here at work,
our, you know, DP,
director on a lot of stuff,
he was like, you know, I gotta tell you,
I got a DJ deck recently too.
I was like, really?
I was like, dude, we should
get together and like,
do some DJ stuff.
Some double DJ.
So it was like three weeks
before Mythicon that we finally
were able to get together
and Ben is, you know,
very technical and so when,
he had all these things
to show me that I had not figured out,
and so over the course of
a few hours of him like,
showing me some transitions
and he had his own deck
and he would show me stuff
and then he would try
to figure out how to do it on his deck,
on my deck.
How's his deck
compared to yours, he got a bigger deck?
His deck is not as good as mine.
Oh, okay.
But he probably paid more
'cause I got mine used.
Okay, well interesting.
So he was teaching me
things I didn't know,
which was pretty much
everything, and I just,
I'll tell you and I
don't know how much Ben,
I don't know what his
perspective on it was,
but like when we parted ways that night,
I stayed there for another
three hours freaking out
and trying to practice 'cause I was like,
oh my God, I didn't realize
how much I didn't know
and now I'm gonna suck so bad.
Well, had you been like,
before Ben showed up,
were you like putting together a playlist
and like, practicing
transitions and stuff?
Like, what was like,
'cause I know so little
about how this works from
a technical perspective.
I don't know anything about it.
I had to, you gotta pick a bunch of songs
and from the reading I
did, it's like however long
your set is, you need to have three times
that amount of songs.
So I'm like, I need to be ready
to do two hours at Mythicon.
Now that reduced some,
but two, so at the time
I was thinking I need six hours of music
if I'm transitioning.
So explain that to people.
Because when you play, when
you're reading the room,
you have to be able to go with
the flow of what's happening.
If you're not connecting with an audience,
you've got to change it up.
You gotta be able to go
in a different direction,
like a different style.
You have to like, and I have
kind of an eclectic style,
like I like some pop stuff.
Like, I'm a fan of the Harry Styles album.
I like to play some Dua Lipa, but then
I'm a real hip hop guy.
So I really like that, and
I like old school hip hop
and I like some, a lot of new hip hop,
but if people aren't into
that and they don't know
the new stuff, then I've
only got the old stuff
and I can't keep going back,
and within any one song,
if it gets a little
boring, you kinda wanna
transition to a new song.
I mean, if a song's five
minutes or four minutes,
in that, in a certain, in a dance setting.
Yeah, I don't think you
want, sometimes you just
don't wanna play more
than like half of it.
Yeah.
You know, you wanna keep things moving.
Like, the moment they
start to get a little,
okay, I'm, everybody's
not loving this song,
you gotta move on and then
you gotta figure out a way
to do it that is as seamless as possible.
Right.
You know, so you can move
from one thing to the next.
So I understand all these principles.
Like, I know how to read a
room, I have my taste in music.
I only wanna play things
that I like that then
also connect with people.
So I had all these exercises
in my mind that was like,
song selection matters so
much, and then technique
like beat matching where
you have a song and then
you queue up another
song in your earphones
and you match the beat.
So like you move the tempo
up or down to be in sync
with the other song
and then you find a way
to start playing it and
mixing the two together
and then subtly transitioning
in a way that seems like
you've done sort of a remix.
And that's why DJ has like
headphones that are like
one ear on, one ear off.
You're listening to what
the crowd's hearing,
but then you're listening what
you're queuing up and playing
because like, you don't
want this long intro.
Oh yeah, this is an album
cut and like, the artist
is talking or doing a skit or something.
This is like, you're
gonna kill the room if,
you gotta start it at the right time.
So all of these, and there's so much more
that I still don't know,
but in terms of being able
to transition, I mean, and then
you can do like key matching
'cause you don't wanna be blending stuff
that are in different keys.
It'll be like dissonant and it doesn't,
it just is like, ick.
There's so much technique that
goes into it that I'm just
scratching the surface,
but I made up my mind
in the limited amount of time I had,
I was like, I cannot,
and it was that night
that I kind of decided, I
cannot put this much pressure
on myself to like, be a
technically proficient DJ.
I just, I'm not there yet
if, but I can't lose sight
of some key realities.
The first is there is, this is
gonna be the most supportive,
enthusiastic crowd to just,
and a lot of them will know
the story that I'm telling
like, that where this,
that I'm just getting started with this.
Right.
And all they want to
do is just watch me try
this new endeavor and
support me through it.
It was, there probably won't
be a gathering to watch,
I'll just skip ahead and tell you.
Based on my experience, there was not,
I don't think there is a
DJ whose first public set
was in such a supportive,
enthusiastic environment ever.
Yeah.
You, it may be the most.
It was the.
Supportive debut.
The most awesome.
Yeah.
Crowd for a DJ who was
just getting started.
It was amazing.
I was right about that.
I was actually watching
the DJ who started the night.
Yeah.
He's good.
And I was like,
I was like trying to
get his read on things.
I actually, he was playing it
really close with the vest.
I couldn't get much of
a read, but I could.
On what?
On his read of the crowd or
on the crowd's read of him?
No, on the fact that
like, 'cause he was kind
of down there in the back kind
of hanging out in the back.
Oh, while I was up there.
While you were up there and I'm like,
here's this guy that's
been playing for the crowd
and the crowd is really into it already.
Right.
I mean I'm sure he had been
educated on like, you know.
I was really self-conscious.
He was coming up to do this.
Yeah, there was a DJ who
played and warmed up the crowd
because when our stage show ended,
everybody made their way
to the tent and the DJ
started playing, the dance
party started and then after
like 45 minutes is when
I came on and took over.
And well, and.
I like literally, I walked
on and then he walked off.
And specifically.
And then he watched and I
was really self-conscious.
Well let's get into the details of like,
how you actually started the
set, like what that involved,
because that was what was a trip to A,
to be there to witness.
So yeah.
But also to then like,
turn and watch this guy
'cause like you didn't have a.
This is what I want to know.
It wasn't a typical
introduction on any level.
Nope,
but the, just to finish my thought though,
the second point was I,
they're gonna be supportive
was the first point.
Second point that I wanted
to keep in the forefront
of my mind is that like, I'm
not gonna focus on technique.
I'm just gonna focus on song selection.
If at the end of the day I
play a song all the way through
and then I play the next
song all the way through,
I can just do that and it will be okay.
It, song selection is
so much more important
than any technique at this
point in the game for me.
So I spent a lot of time
like amassing playlist,
private playlists that like
got me to six hours of music
and then I just started working
on putting that playlist
together in an order and saying, you know,
you set cue points so if you
need to skip forward in a song,
you can skip forward on
beat and it won't feel like
I'm just guessing at when I
transition to the next song.
If you can skip to the kind
of the outro of the song
and then transition, it
becomes a little easier
and then, but so that was my focus,
and then once I got my set list down,
then I did start just
trying to get proficient
at going from song to song.
It sounds simple, but I was just like,
I just have to keep it simple,
but then I also wanted,
I was like, well I have
to reveal my DJ name.
The first time anyone's gonna hear it
is gonna be from stage and well, I'm like,
see DJs, I know they can talk,
but like in the purest form,
in my opinion, a DJ doesn't
talk but I need to talk
'cause I need to say what my DJ name is.
So I said, you know what I'm gonna do?
I'm going to record little sounds.
I'm gonna record little moments
that announce my DJ name.
So, you know, I actually got
Mark over and he recorded me,
and then we like put some
effects on some stuff that like,
then I could load it on my
deck and like hit buttons
and start playing stuff
that would, you know,
reveal my DJ name, so like this.
Elkhound .
That's my voice.
Oh, I remember hearing that.
Elkhound .
Now, in a large tent with a lot of people
making a lot of noise,
there was a lot of this.
As this began to happen,
this is my vantage point.
Well, hold on and let me
tell you how it happened.
Okay.
So I said, well I'm just
not gonna get up there
and start playing these sound effects.
I've got, I need an intro track.
So I had like music that I
came out to like a wrestler,
instrumental, kind of like
Viking with a big beat music,
and then when that was over I did just,
I hit him with an Elkhound.
Elkhound.
And then I hit him with a Snugglebaby.
Snugglebaby.
And I knew at this point that people
were gonna be like, what?
Yeah.
What?
Lots of leaning over.
First of all, a lot of
cheering, I mean ear shattering.
Oh my gosh.
Deafening cheering.
'Cause they were reacting to my antlers
and my freaking fur cape.
But then a lot of people were like, what?
Greg, who at that point was getting ready
for like, the inaugural tweet.
Elkhound.
He leans over to me and
he's like, how do you,
what is it, El, Eltron?
Eltron.
El Train, I heard El Train from people.
And I was like, Elkhound
and I want to take
full responsibility for not
including the parentheses
in the Mythical.
It was, I know.
'Cause he was like, how do you spell that,
and I was like, it's Elkhound
and it's Snugglebaby,
and obviously I was team
parentheses, but I think
it created a great way
for you to clarify it.
I got up there and then I
hit 'em with the Elkhound
and the Snugglebaby, and then
I had recorded, I was like,
I don't want to give a
speech, but I just felt like,
I felt like I needed to give a speech,
but I didn't wanna give a speech.
So I called Jenna and I said,
I need you to come over here
for, I'm recording some stuff.
I need your voice because
I know you were the voice
of an alien in "Independence Day."
She was the voice of the orb.
Yeah.
Well.
It's the same.
It was, I thought it was AI
but it, she explained to me.
Okay, it was an alien.
It's like a singularity of a whole.
In "Independence Day" 2?
Yes.
Independent, oh, "Independence Day" 2.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, you told me all this
when we were recording.
I did.
Because I was wrong about it.
I thought you were AI.
You're an alien singularity.
You recorded the scratch
track because you worked
for the director and then
they loved it so much
that they just kept you in the movie.
They did, yeah.
They did not recast
from your scratch track.
So I was like, I need your voice.
So I had her come in and record.
Ad lib speech now.
Wow.
I've never heard you make that effect.
Ad lib speech now, ad lib speech now.
See I'm doing a little DJing right now.
Ad lib speech now.
Yeah, and then I, in there,
Jenna was sitting over there.
Mark was recording me.
I ad libbed a speech.
Yeah, what, yeah.
So.
That was evident.
And so then I said, well I'm
just gonna play the speech
for people and I'm going, I recorded it,
it was two minutes and 41 seconds long
and I decided it would be
hilarious if I play the speech
and then I start gesturing
as if I'm actually giving
the speech, like I'm an
animatronic version of a DJ.
Yeah.
And like the Hall of Presidents at Disney.
I just thought that would be awesome.
Yeah.
So I started the speech
and then after a while
I stopped pantomiming and I started,
I faded in a beat underneath
it to make it seem cooler.
Right.
Even though.
So that was on the fly decision.
No, I planned to do it,
but it wasn't in a track.
It seemed natural.
I had to do it, I had to fade it up,
so like this like, SZA,
I faded in some SZA.
Yeah, that's always a good idea.
I'm not gonna play the
the whole speech for you,
but I'll play a little bit.
So Elkhound .
That's my DJ name.
This is me.
Yo, I'm not, well I don't think I'm,
I'm not really gonna say yo.
I don't, I think I'm just gonna say things
that I would normally say
in like, my normal life,
but this is kind of, this is,
but I could go in full persona
and I guess as DJ, you know
what, let's meet halfway.
Just call me Elkhound , you know?
Yeah, you know.
Then I know that
we'll be on the same page.
And then.
That was playing.
That was like 30, you
know, 20 seconds of the,
there's still two minutes of
the speech left.
Right, right.
But there's music, I put music underneath.
So it was like, everyone
was just kind of like,
understanding this is
the most awkward speech
that is completely ad libbed.
Like there's, it's not edited in any way.
This is exactly what I.
Really?
I did an ad lib speech
and then I didn't like it.
Oh, this is a take two.
This is take two.
Oh.
But it's totally different than take one.
Really?
Different concept.
I went in a different direction.
So yeah, I recorded this ad lib speech,
didn't edit any of it,
threw some effects on it,
and then I was like, I'll just
bring some SZA underneath it,
you know, and yeah, so
there's two minutes left.
You want me to keep
playing the whole thing
or is it a little, it's awkward.
Yeah, I mean you can.
You're the DJ.
It's, I wanted
to capture the awkwardity of the moment,
like just this thing that's
like, I'm calling myself this.
You know, if you are willing to call me
Elkhound , that says something
about our relationship.
'Cause if you're willing to call me that,
that says something
about our relationship.
Oh yeah.
See you, there's that.
Like, I just don't think
anybody off the street would
be comfortable looking me
in the eyes and calling me Elkhound .
It's just such a, it's the thing
that normal people wouldn't do.
Right.
Like if somebody asked me to do that,
look 'em in the eyes
and call him Elkhound ,
I would be like, I'm gonna order coffee
from somewhere else, you know?
And Jenna, you're sitting
there while this is happening?
Yes, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, because later on, you know,
she had to be the one to record.
Elkhound mode.
Yeah, that was one of my favorite parts.
Yeah, and then of course
she also recorded.
Snugglebaby mode.
Yeah, and then she also recorded.
Elkhound's doing business as Snugglebaby.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
You're welcome.
I like that.
That's my favorite one.
Elkhound's doing business as Snugglebaby.
Yeah, because I determined
that like, Elkhound mode
was like, we're going for
it, we're getting down,
and then Snugglebaby mode
is more of like, oh man,
I'm kind of having some
feelings to go along with this.
I was trying to figure out.
And the tempo goes more like,
to like 90.
The difference.
You were trying to figure
out the difference?
It wasn't immediately obvious to me,
but I'm a novice.
It's more,
Snugglebaby's more laid back
and in other I couldn't go in,
honestly I didn't, I never went
into full Snugglebaby mode,
which would be more of.
Slow jams?
Very, not too sexy, but
just very laid back.
Like almost like, lounge, bob
your head kind of a thing.
Maybe stroke something, could be a pet.
Okay, all right.
And then Elkhound mode, you're like,
gonna be sore the next day.
If there's moshing that's gonna happen,
it's gonna be with Elkhound.
Right.
The one that I never got to play,
'cause they didn't have enough pads.
Elkhound .
E-L-K-H-O-U-N-D, open parenthesis,
S-N-U-G-G-L-E-B-A-B-Y, closed parenthesis.
Yeah, that's probably
a good choice that you.
I chose.
You didn't like that one?
I gave the proper spelling.
I liked your delivery.
It was a little overbearing.
I'm questioning my entire life right now.
That's the one I used.
That was, and I'm glad you used that.
I'm questioning my entire life right now.
And you used that pretty liberally.
That is when I first started recording.
That was an honest reaction.
This was honestly one of the first things
that I said when recording.
I'm questioning my entire life right now.
So now it's part of my tag,
that's a signature tag for Elkhound .
Well okay, so let me
interject at this point.
These are all my sound ups.
You're good to go.
About, I feel like
what this represents at this point,
including that one that you just said,
and I think that last one,
I'm questioning my entire life right,
now really illustrates
this, and I think it is,
it also speaks to the
fact, to the environment
in which you did this and that is,
and I think this is a beautiful thing,
so your apprehensiveness
associated with this endeavor
and your questioning yourself.
I'm questioning my entire life right now.
It is, it's a part of the introduction.
Yes.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's just like.
And I wanted to bring
my honest self to it.
And I think you succeed,
well, you succeeded.
Like, you got all of me.
And I think that's, you know, first of all
I, you know, it's an
overused term that we are,
that authenticity is
valued in entertainment,
and I think that the internet
and specifically social media
and social media entertainment
like YouTube, et cetera,
has, it's the reason,
honestly, it's the reason
that we do this podcast now
in the way that we do it.
It's the reason that we shared
our deconstruction stories.
Right.
Which is the reason that I made
the album about deconstruction.
Real, man.
A real.
It's, there's a
leaning into the, like I'm,
I could put on airs and try
to appear to be something
or whatever, but this is
actually my authentic self.
You wrapped that into the
actual presentation itself.
And made it performance art.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it was at this, that's when I started
to really get excited was, I'm
taking some risk in something
that can't be compared to anything else.
Like, I'm doing something that
I want people to scratch their heads.
I wanted to feel weird, but it's like,
people were so supportive,
I don't even think they felt those things.
And that's the second part of that is,
you can only kind of do that
in a really supportive place.
It's almost like you.
No, I will do it anywhere.
Well, but I'm saying for the first time.
But yes.
You created what you might
call a director's commentary
that you would then see in the documentary
about your DJ debut, but you folded it
into the actual debut
itself, if that makes sense.
This is the director's commentary.
You see me up there on stage.
Yeah, yeah.
I was questioning my entire life,
but no, you're just like,
I'm questioning my entire life right now.
I don't know how many people
and people, I think most
people experienced it as,
Link is very weird and very odd.
And I'm not surprised,
'cause I know him.
And that's everything
that I expected, and so
that kind of makes this fun
and cool and enjoyable, which it did,
but I think probably
some people were like,
oh he's, it is performance art,
but it's honest performance art.
I, when I went up there on that stage,
I was not nervous.
I went from three weeks earlier
to being a complete wreck
to determining that with my
criteria and like, you know,
that like I wasn't gonna lose perspective
and I was not gonna
let go of my insistence
on having the time of my life,
and I am so, I've never
had anything that I felt
so much pressure and
then got past it so that
when it happened I could
just be just there for it,
and let me tell you, I
actually, that was my experience
and we've done a lot of stuff
that I wish I could go back
and be able to pull that mind trick
and, but something about
the setting was so special
that the safety net was so supportive.
Yeah.
That it's not, you know,
it's unrealistic to expect
that I could go back and
apply it 100% to something
in the past or even in
the future for like,
our next demanding thing
that like, 'cause you know,
there was also like, nothing
really depends on this.
You know, it's like if
I fall flat on my face,
I'm just gonna get up and
keep going and make a joke,
because once we got
past all of this stuff,
like this opening part, I still
didn't speak the entire set.
I just started playing my set
and I had a decent number,
I had a bunch of ideas for how
I wanted to transition stuff,
and I would say a third of the time,
I pretty much accomplished
what I was going for
a third of the time.
Okay.
And I think that a lot
of things like, you know,
a lot of times it, I would
just, I'd hit the button
and I would say like, Elkhound .
Yeah.
Well, over half the time
that I played Elkhound,
I was trying to cue the
next song in my headphones.
Okay.
It did often come at interesting times.
Yeah, it was never.
He's making some interesting choices.
I was like, 'cause I'll
listen on my headphones
and I'm queuing up the song
and you can't hear that,
but somehow the Elkhound.
Yeah.
You can't predict.
Still goes out there.
What Elkhound or Snugglebaby.
I'll be, oh I just said
Elkhound by accident.
I better say Snugglebaby now,
and then I would hit
Snugglebaby and then I would
cue my thing and it just got.
And it got a cheer every time.
It got a cheer every time,
and it got to a point
where I was like, oh, I'm
screwing up, and if you just act
like I meant to do it, after
that intro that I gave,
they're gonna believe that
I'm meant to do everything.
Like, even when I played the speech,
like after like 45
seconds into the speech,
I accidentally started the speech over.
Yeah, I thought that was intentional.
And I was like, oh that's,
yeah, that's a weird choice.
I'm going on instinct now.
I guess my body wanted that to
be even weirder than it was.
So I gave the speech twice, the first half
of the speech twice,
and then it was weird.
Maybe I just got looser,
I got some confidence,
but there were a couple
of points towards the end
of the set, like I was gonna
go from Michael McDonald,
"I Keep Forgetting," into
"Regulate" by, you know,
the G-Funk Classic, which samples it,
and I could not get "Regulate" to play.
I could not, I don't, I still don't know.
You don't know what happened?
I couldn't transition to the next song,
and that's why like, I keep forgetting
it went away to nothing.
People would always cheer 'cause they,
it was like, oh he's
going to the next song.
They're so gracious, and
then I'm like struggling
to figure out why the song's not playing,
and then I ended up having
to go back and just play more
of Michael McDonald 'cause
I couldn't figure out
how to get to it and I was
like, well, okay, I just move on
and then, and that was in
the latter half of the set,
and then the next like, so by
the time we got to the ending,
like I had, the other thing
was things got squirrelly
'cause I had so much music,
but I had like an hour of music
I wanted to play and I
had 15 minutes to play it.
So I had to start making
choices of what I was skipping
and what I was playing.
Because there's
a noise ordinance that we had to abide by.
Well yeah, at a certain point
you just gotta wrap it up.
It was, I mean, it was after
midnight and so I'm making
all these choices on the fly
and then trying to figure out
how I'm gonna transition from song to song
between songs I've never,
it's never, I've never.
I'm literally doing
everything in the moment
and that's what got the
best of me that when I like,
these fundamental mistakes, like,
oh, this slider's over here.
So this song is never, they're
never gonna hear this song.
So the set kind of just
started to fall apart
a little bit by the end but,
and then at the very end
I did get the microphone and I
gave a speech and I was like,
you know what, all good
things must come to an end.
Thanks for coming out to Mythicon.
This has been amazing and then I pressed,
I had it all cued up and I was pressing,
I was gonna play the
last song, "Roll Out."
Yep.
So that everybody could leave.
By Ludacris,
wouldn't play.
Yeah, yeah.
It would not play.
Was that when you started saying, I don't,
I can't get the last song to play?
Yeah, that's when I
said, I would end this.
I thought that might be part of.
If I could get the last song to play.
The beautiful thing about your style.
And everybody left.
Is that anything could be intentional.
Anything.
Or unintentionally, no one knows.
Yes, except for now.
Yeah, now they know.
So now when people come to my
sets, they're gonna be like,
oh, it must all be a mistake.
Yeah, right.
But nope, I'm gonna get better.
It's all gonna be intentional,
and then I finally
got "Roll Out" to play and
then when "Roll Out" was over,
I had one more song queued
up, like my walk off song
and I pressed it, nothing happened,
and I just walked off stage.
Yeah.
And it was just like, I was
like, this has been amazing.
I'm not gonna let any of this
get to me, and I was ecstatic,
but there was some, in my mind
there was some huge fails,
but the biggest thing about it
was, I was up there on stage
and I was like in, I was
in this world of like,
okay, I'm gonna get started.
I didn't have my headphones.
So like right at the beginning I'm like.
Yeah, there's a lot of details.
I lean over to, and like Jenna walks up,
and right, you walked
up and Ben walked up.
I, well I could see.
I was like.
I was lost.
I could tell
by your body language
that something was wrong.
Right.
I was like, I was looking around.
A DJ without his headphones.
I was looking at the other
DJ's headphones and their,
his jacks were too big
'cause he's a big time DJ.
He's got an eighth inch jack.
I didn't wanna say
how big his deck was, but his deck was.
His deck was twice as big as mine.
Maybe four times.
Okay, yeah, and his jacks
were twice as big in my jack.
So I leaned over to Jenna, I
was like, I need my headphones.
They're in my computer bag in
the other house in the top,
and then come to find out,
Jenna sprints over there and I.
Sprinted.
I started the speech, so
I'm doing the speech now,
and then Jenna, when you came back,
you fell flat on your face.
Oh, I ate it.
Oh, bad, yeah.
I sprinted all the way to the house.
I like, there was some
crew members in there
and I was like, emergency, out of the way,
and I like grabbed your headphones,
sprinted all the way back,
and then bound up the stairs
and I hit the last stair
to the stage and just, bam.
In front of everybody.
In front of everybody, ate it.
Straight down on my knees.
I did not see this.
Elkhound was in his own world,
'cause I was giving my speech.
About half the audience.
I was giving my speech.
Jenna was falling on her face.
Your headphones were like, silver.
They were just Christy's
headphones from going on planes.
But how big were they?
They were like Bose headphones.
They weren't too big.
Okay.
Yeah, for some reason I can't picture 'em.
But then I'm looking around
and the crew is on stage.
Lily's on stage, Lincoln's on stage.
My dad is on stage, they're all dancing.
Christy's on stage.
Yeah, she was.
You know, Christy's not in the public eye.
She made a choice that
she was gonna be out there
supporting me and it was
just a, it was so sweet.
It was beautiful.
You were on stage.
I was.
David Hill was like my hype
man over on the other side.
David Hill has a gift.
Oh my God.
I can't go anywhere without that guy now.
He is amazing, and like
when I played "New Light,"
which is like me and
Lily and Lincoln's song,
like they came over and I put my arms
around 'em and we're dancing.
That's also not something
you typically see
at a DJ set, is it?
The DJ's kids.
They're like.
Yeah.
Come up and dance with him,
but again, I was thinking
that at the time.
I was like, what a interesting,
I was just, I'd been thinking about this.
Tell me what you thought about
the whole thing that you had said.
Well, I was thinking the way that it was
a great culmination to Mythicon in general
because I was like, what
an interesting world that,
you know, the two of us and our team
and the Mythical Beasts
have created in which this,
what is happening right now is possible.
Like you, your dad from Myrtle,
north Myrtle Beach, South
Carolina is up there like.
Dancing to JID.
Doing his dance.
Dancing a jig to JID.
And you know, on the same
stage where the night before,
Jessie and I had done
this country music thing.
Wild, man.
For the same, essentially
the same group of people,
and then your kids are up there.
My, Shepard's up there like.
Shepard's up there.
Shepard's trying to get
a dance a little bit.
Yeah, it was awesome.
And I was just like this, yeah.
I was, so in terms of
that, I was just like,
what a inter, what an
incredible atmosphere
for this kind of thing to happen,
and then, I mean, ultimately
I was thinking this is,
I don't think anything that
you did was surprising.
I think that all of it was, I didn't know.
None of it
was expected.
I've learned that.
You couldn't have expected anything I did.
If you had asked me what
mistakes did you make
that I picked up on, I would be like,
well, obviously the end when
he couldn't play that song,
and maybe one other time when the songs,
when it just kind of
stopped and it didn't go
into the next song.
Right.
And then I would've said that,
I think for the most part,
everything else was
intentional which is again,
which is why I'm saying that
the style that you're embracing
is kind of like, ah, you can't
really go wrong, you know?
That's right.
As long as something comes out.
Snugglebaby.
It was amazing.
I had such a good time.
I'm not saying I did amazing.
I'm saying it was an amazing experience.
Like, it was just like,
just putting it out there
and just the exuberance of the crowd.
There wasn't enough room for me.
Everybody was facing the
stage and watching me
and watching all of us on stage dance
and kind of dancing in place,
but it was kind of like
watching a concert, but it
was just a DJ, you know,
which was cool.
Yeah, which I've never,
I guess that's what happens when people
go to like DJ concerts, like
that you're there for the DJ.
Yeah, I guess so.
Never been there either.
I mean, I assume that's what happens.
That's the other thing is
that like, I've never been
to a club like, dancing and
here I am trying to be a DJ.
I might need to start going
to clubs to see what they do,
but it's a different thing.
Like, that's not the type of music I play.
I think I'm more of a
barbecue DJ, honestly.
Oh, really?
But I can, okay.
Don't want me to sell it short?
I guess what I'm thinking is
that regardless of what you,
'cause I know you wanna talk
about your other experiences.
I have to tell you about.
The next thing you did,
but for better or for
worse, anything that we do
for the rest of our lives,
including your DJing,
the majority of people who
are gonna be there to see it,
if they may, if they
heard about it happening
and they're showing up to see it,
they're gonna be coming to
it because of everything else
that you have done up
to that point, right.
I mean, let's just face it.
Same goes for me in my music.
It's not like all of a
sudden, regardless of how well
either one of these endeavors would go,
it's not like unless we like
go, like you go to a festival
where everybody's there for
a bunch of other reasons.
If people are like, Elkhound
is doing a show tonight,
the majority of people
are gonna be there, I like Link.
I like Link and I also like to dance.
That's the Venn diagram,
and so I'm gonna be there,
and so I think that ultimately
that's a beautiful thing,
and what it means, what
to me what that means is,
is that with the exception of things like,
hey, I'll DJ your party,
people who I don't know,
but if you're like, hey,
I'm gonna just do this show,
virtually every time you step
into this, onto the stage,
it's going to be people who are showing up
because they want to see you
DJ in the way that you DJ
at whatever point in
the process you're at.
So it's like, okay, year two,
Snugglebaby.
Oh, I'm not.
I'm not stopping.
Year two Elkhound is going to be
12 months more proficient at DJing.
Oh yeah.
Than year one, but the people,
and that's gonna change
the experience, but the people are there
because they're just like,
I just wanna be there
to see year two of Elkhound or vice versa.
Allow me to illustrate how wrong you are.
Well, they were so hyped,
the crowd, they were.
Oh, I'm not talking about there.
Yeah.
I'm talking about, I flew
home on Sunday and then
the next day, Monday, was
Halloween, and I had agreed
to DJ Lando's friend's Halloween party.
But that's consistent
with what I'm saying.
Hold on.
That's a different thing.
Just let me tell you about it.
It was the most different thing.
So it was Lando's 12
year old, like, you know,
group of sixth grader friends
and then their parents,
which were all friends
because of football,
and then the house that it was at,
Lando's friend has a younger sister,
so all of her friends were
there and some of those parents.
So it was like.
How big of a crowd?
Two group, probably 50 people,
but then like how many
middle schoolers there were,
probably, you know, 15.
And they're all in costumes?
Yeah, they're all in costumes,
because I'm going to,
there was like in the
backyard, they had like,
one little speaker set up
and then, but it was actually
pretty loud and a dance floor set up.
Okay, got it.
And then a little fog machine thing,
like Brian, the dad
who's a friend of mine,
he like set all this stuff up.
It was pretty cool, and then so like
they were gonna play music.
I was gonna DJ a little bit
and then they were gonna
trick or treat and then they come back
and I was gonna DJ some more and the dads
go trick or treating with
the kids while the moms
hang out at the party, and I was like,
yes, I'm gonna DJ this.
I need to get some more experience.
I bring my deck, I set everything
up an hour ahead of time.
I come back and then
everybody starts showing up
and I start playing.
Well, hold on.
What, are you in?
In Elkhound garb?
Yeah.
No, I was not planning on it,
but I couldn't have anyway
because it was on the truck
coming back from Mythicon.
Okay.
So I wore my camo outfit
that I actually had worn
the day before at, no, I
had worn it two days before
at the Mythicon brunch,
like my camo outfit.
But you're still Elkhound at this point.
I still am.
This isn't just Link?
No, no, no.
Yeah, I was still Elkhound
but I just wasn't in my garb.
Okay.
'Cause I didn't have it.
Right, right, right.
People did ask me who I was dressed up as,
and I was like, I wore this two days ago,
but I said, okay, I'm a camouflage giraffe
if you want me to be.
'Cause if you had your costume on,
people would just think
you had on a costume.
Yep.
That's an interesting thing about
going to a Halloween party.
Yeah, which would've been
cool, but I didn't have it.
Okay.
I decided I was going to play
the music and I was going
to dance and I was gonna
like, act like I was
fully committed to it, even
if there wasn't any kids
on the dance floor and
there weren't, but then.
Yeah, middle school, man.
Middle school.
Middle school in front of their parents.
In front of their parents, it was like
the potentially most, it could
have been very humiliating,
and I tested that theory
because like they're up there.
I finally get 'em on the
dance floor and they were,
you know, they were, I
didn't play my speech.
How'd you get 'em on
the dance floor, waving?
Like, directing them in?
What was I playing?
I think I played some Harry Styles.
You know, you play a little
bit of "Late Night Talking,"
get 'em out there, and then I
had a stack of Post-It notes
and I said, hey guys, if
you have any requests,
write 'em down, and they got excited.
So they started writing down
stuff and then I'm looking
at the Post-it notes, and then
it was like, "Baby Shark."
I'm like, are you freaking kidding me?
I could have told you
that was gonna happen.
I mean like, "Dancing Queen."
I'm like, oh, okay.
Yeah, man, you gave the control
to a bunch of middle schoolers.
And I, well I didn't give 'em control.
I said, I'm not playing
any of the requests.
Yeah, you denied it all.
And this one girl, and
this is the younger girls,
came up to me and she just kept saying,
I told you to play "Sexy and I Know It."
When are you gonna play
"Sexy and I Know It?"
And I was like, I'll play it next.
Then she's like, and then I
played "Sexy and I Know It,"
and they loved it, and then
they were moving and I was like,
okay, I gotta play by their rules,
and I put on "Dancing
Queen" and they were just,
I don't know what it is
about "Dancing Queen,"
but they went nuts.
Yeah.
They went, middle schoolers
going nuts over that,
and I was like, yes, I have them.
You know, I, this was like my
third or fourth song in a row.
Yeah.
That kept 'em on the dance floor.
Not "Baby Shark."
And then, I ain't doing no "Baby Shark,"
and then all of a sudden they're like.
You gotta draw the line somewhere.
They're like, having
the time of their lives,
singing along and then, and
I'm just standing back there
just like saying, hey,
ah, this is working.
Yeah, taking requests.
I'm a little embarrassed,
but it's working,
and then all of a sudden the music stops.
Like, and I look down and
like my USB had been tweaked
and it had come disconnected
and there was no,
because, you know, and
then it had to reboot.
So like, all these kids just
like turn and they're like, oh.
I was oh'ed by 17 middle
schoolers, and I was just like,
all I could do was like, make a face
and go, I, it wasn't me.
Something happened to my computer.
Your computer died?
And then no, the USB came disconnected,
so my deck disconnected and
then when you reconnect it.
Oh.
It has to, you have to
restart the program.
Oh.
I mean this is like a,
you know, they were.
They were gone.
It was like they disappeared
from the dance hall.
You lost 'em.
I lost 'em, I literally lost them.
I did, I couldn't even see them.
Oh my God.
Where are the middle schoolers
that I'm trying my best to please?
What mode does Elkhound
go into when that happens?
There needs to be a third mode.
Defeated mode, I mean.
Panic mode.
Crap, man.
Elkhound enters panic mode.
No, no, no, I got it.
Get Jenna to say that.
No, I was fully prepared.
I'm questioning my entire life right now.
Okay, yeah.
You know, I was definitely
prepared for that,
and I was, I made up my mind.
I'm like, this could be
soul crushingly humiliating.
This could be the end of.
And I'm not gonna let that happen.
We went trick or treating,
had a good time, came back.
I was like, I'm gonna redeem myself.
I'm gonna play some music, got
'em back on the dance floor
and then like, they were
running off other people,
and then the parents,
some of which are like,
good friends of mine
got on the dance floor
and they were like, all
right, DJ, let's have this,
and then I was like,
they put me on the spot
and I'm like, what?
I gotta play something, now I
gotta figure out how to make.
"Baby Got Back."
My friends dance and I played a song
and they didn't like it.
These are my friends.
They weren't even humoring me,
and then I played another
song, they didn't like it,
and then I like, I was like, all right.
I just, I have to pander.
I gotta play like "Party in the USA."
I just gotta go there.
Well, you know, that was one of the.
That's like a huge song.
One of the observations that I made
'cause I've never ever.
I like the song.
I've never thought about a
DJ before until you did it.
Like, other than like, are they play.
God, it's hard.
But one of the things that
I was able to observe,
even in a really supportive crowd like
all the Mythical Beasts, is that if,
you could put two songs, you know,
you could show me two
songs and BPM is the same,
perceived, like energy is the same.
Yes.
And I would be like, yeah, both of these
are like, crowd hype inducing
songs, and then it turns out
that for whatever intangible
reason that is very difficult
to anticipate, no, only
one of them is what
the crowd is gonna like.
Right.
And that to me is what something clicked.
That's when something
clicked for me is like,
oh, that's really the job of a DJ.
They can't, you know, people.
And knowing what's gonna happen.
Yeah, and they're not gonna,
it's, they don't wanna fake it, you know?
Even my friends didn't wanna fake it
and they were just like, come on and play,
and I finally got 'em
with that, and then I,
so I played a couple of
songs and I was like,
building momentum and
everybody was having fun,
and then all of a sudden, the
same thing happened again.
Everything just died.
Oh God.
And a woman our age, or
like, she's in her 30s
that I did not know.
Oh no.
Like she, you know, she
had an emotional reaction
to the fact that when they
were finally getting into it.
Oh gosh, I'm getting, oh, I'm.
This woman.
My face is getting red.
This woman that I did not
know, like when the music
just dies, just whips
around and looks at me
and is like, dude!
Gah, what?
Come on.
She's like, and I'm like,
it's like it's one thing
for like some middle school,
but like, and you know what?
I forgive her.
I lured her into a trance
of enjoyment that then
I snatched her out of
it, and all she could do
was just emote at who?
The DJ that she didn't know.
For all she knew.
Yeah.
It was the guy that was paid
to be there and wear full camo.
You certainly look like it.
I didn't fit in with any
of my many adults there,
you know, so it's like, that hurt, man.
Hold on, so what happened that time?
I said I'm sorry, it's my computer.
Ah, ah, you know.
What happened?
The USB disconnected.
But how does that happen?
Because I had to raise up
my laptop by putting it
on top of the suitcase
that I brought my deck in
and the suitcase was empty and it was
a plastic shell suitcase
and it sagged in such that
when the laptop sagged in, it disconnected
the USB adapter to my deck.
So it unplugged it and it
just slowly happens whenever,
like if you bump the table or something.
Doesn't like Questlove have
like a branded like, lock
that you can put on your cable?
Doesn't any DJ worth this
salt have like a setup
where that doesn't happen?
I'm buying one today.
Yeah.
This ain't gonna happen again.
Why didn't you buy one that night?
But it, dude, I'm gonna tell you,
I went from the best DJ
experience that any DJ
could ever have to one
of the most humiliating.
Like, I mean, I might
as well have been naked.
How did you recover from that one?
I didn't.
Party over at that point?
Well, I said, I apologized
profusely and then I was like,
I had also hooked up my phone
to the Bluetooth on speaker
and I just started
playing music on my phone
and I shut my laptop.
Oh gosh.
I shut my laptop and I just started
playing music from my phone.
Oh.
And I was so disappointed.
Like I was just so, I wasn't mad.
I wasn't, you know, I was
just disappointed, you know.
I wanted to.
What was Christy
saying at this point, where was she?
She was like, just play
some stuff on your phone,
and then like, when I started
playing stuff on my phone,
they kept dancing and it was okay,
and then I tried to skip to the next song.
It's like, why did you skip that song?
It's like they were, the
people were not letting up.
Yeah, yeah.
They were like.
You're also in Los Angeles.
Like, one of the things that
I've learned multiple times
is that so many people, whether they work
in the entertainment
industry or they are so close
to the entertainment
industry, that's why most acts
don't like to perform in LA,
because it's the judgiest,
even if they're your friends.
Yeah.
It's the judgiest crowd in the world
because this is like the
center of entertainment,
and so the standards and the
way they look at everything,
that puts you in a really tough position.
I, yeah.
I just, I mean I literally,
I had to shut down my system.
I just, it failed.
It literally failed,
and then I'm just a dude
playing songs from his phone,
but that did salvage it.
I mean, I literally
almost killed the party
like those two times and then
there were two other times
when I just bumped the
USB and it just stopped
for like a second.
There's another way to see
this that may be encouraging.
I have another way.
I mean, I have some
conclusions, but go ahead.
Is that you, what you got was, in this
second party situation is you
were tangibly appreciating
the power that you hold as a DJ.
Yeah, it's, it was more
power than I could wield.
And it's this thing.
It's like a toddler wielding,
like a heavy steel sword.
I think, you know, this is chapter two
of your memoir, you know.
Chapter one is your
debut and it's wonderful,
and right as soon as you
get out of the gate, you.
Fall flat on my face, just like Jenna.
You run right off the track.
With my headphones.
But you're learning.
It's tough, man.
But one of the lessons is the potential,
the power that you have, and it's just
with great power comes
great responsibility, man.
Like, you're a DJ now.
There's no looking back.
I mean, Elkhound cannot
be put back in the womb.
No, he can't, and you
know what, that's exactly,
I was, I was extremely
disappointed because I wanted,
I had things I wanted to
do and I couldn't do 'em,
and, but I apologized to the
host and he didn't care at all.
Like, nobody really cared,
like after that moment.
What about that woman?
Even the woman, later I talked to her
and she pieced it together
that I was just another dad
at the party who was not being paid,
and she was like, I, you
know, it wasn't a big deal.
It wasn't, we, I played
music from my phone
for another hour, just like I
normally do at get togethers
and it really was fine.
I was just, you know, I did
have a hard time that night
and Christy helped me
out, but you know what?
I'm grateful for both
experiences and I'm grateful
for them being so close together,
'cause now it's kind of
like they kind of blended
in a good way that's like,
I can, I've had my highs,
I've had my lows, you
know, and now I'm just,
I'm gonna pay my dues
and I'm gonna work my way
back up to the top, baby,
me and Diplo.
Yeah, you're like
three years old in DJ years.
I am so grateful for both experiences.
I mean, the second one was just so,
it was just such a learning experience.
You know, if I would have, if I was a more
diligent researcher and
planner and stuff like that,
if I, and then I probably
could have side stepped
some of it, but sometimes you just can't,
you can't replace a good
life lesson, you know?
And I am really excited.
I mean, it's invigorating
to put yourself out there
and do something, especially
when you have people
who can celebrate it,
and then, but even with,
even the other part, this is
like putting yourself out there
and saying, I'm learning something new.
I am really into it.
It's a really fun hobby
that can, you know,
that taps into a lot of my passions
and I can connect with
people and it's something
that I can get better at, you know,
and I can have this, I can just have
another lane of creativity
and growth that is,
it's a different lane from
what we do, and you know,
I now, I'm now experiencing
through that a lot of what
we talked about that you also experienced
with James and the Shame, and
it's just, it is invigorating
and like the good, bad, and
the ugly of it, you know,
and being able to express
myself and say the strange,
very Link-ish ideas I
have, I can just do it.
Like I don't, you know, I don't have to,
I can be fully myself and it,
and there is a part of that
that like if we were doing
this together, wouldn't it,
it would, there would be
some push and pull, right?
'Cause it's like.
If a double DJ.
Yeah, if we were doing double DJ.
That's be a little weird.
Now I will say, I do, I'm,
I think I need to talk
to Ben about being part
of my Elkhound costume.
Like, I'm thinking about,
like, we talked about this,
like putting him in a
baby Bjorn in front of me
with like baby antlers.
Yeah.
And so then I can just like
fist bump for the crowd
and then he works the deck sometimes.
Yeah.
Or whenever I can't figure
out how to play the next song,
why is it not playing?
He just like, he sticks his head and arms
outta my kangaroo pouch
and he does it for me,
and he goes back to.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't wanna do that.
No.
I think Ben could do that.
Yeah. I'm gonna ask Ben if he
wants to do that.
Speaking of that,
that is one thing that in
the bit that I watched Diplo
last night, one of the things
that you did that he didn't do
is a lot of this, a lot
of the fist pumping.
I was dancing a lot.
Yeah, yeah.
You got, you're a very, you're very active
as far as a DJ.
Did I, except for the times
when I was totally bumfuzzled,
like you gave me notes
at the Mythical party
about the look on my face,
what did you think about my,
the way that I held
myself as a DJ on stage?
I think you,
yeah, I don't think you ever
looked like you were lost
even if you were, now that I know
that you were at certain points.
Yeah.
But there were a couple of
times when I can kind of see
that there was this like,
Link has a look on his
face right now that is,
it's hiding something
that's going on underneath.
I didn't know it was that,
oh, you were pressing a button
and something else was happening.
I think it was more like, you were like,
questioning your entire life right now.
Yeah.
But no, I, yeah, I, huge improvement from
the Mythical party.
Oh, good.
You know, the glasses help.
Scene.
Yeah, they do.
You know, it's my wreck.
I'm gonna leave you with a wreck.
Thank you for the love that you gave
to Elkhound .
Thank you for spelling
it with the parentheses.
Thank you for being here for
it, even if you weren't there
for it and you know,
there's gonna be more.
There's gonna be more from Elkhound .
He ain't going away.
Here's my wreck.
I gotta give you a song,
song I'm into as of late.
Hmm, which one am I going with?
Freddie Gibbs, "Feel No Pain,"
featuring Anderson Paak.
I'm a big Anderson Paak fan and I like
the Freddie Gibbs album,
"Soul Sold Separately."
I don't know anything
about him as a person,
but as a rapper, I'm a fan and this is,
that's an, it's an unexpected song
that will take you by surprise.
Didn't mean to start
playing anything right now.
Yeah, so "Feel No Pain."
There you have it, right there.
Thanks for joining us.
Elkhound out.
Continue the conversation with us,
#EarBiscuits and also
remember you can always call
and be a part of the conversation.
1-888-EarPod1.
EarPod1.
So I'm a Starbucks barista
or Starbucks partner,
and we have a Reddit thread
called Starbucks Partners,
and it's so funny because I
was going through our like,
hottest posts and one of them, like one of
the most popular posts on
that Reddit group is Link,
a barista selfie with Link
saying, if anyone sees Link,
get him a grande iced latte with oat milk,
and I just think it's so
funny and I wanted to share it
because you guys need to
know, especially Link,
that Starbucks baristas love you.
There you go.
Thank you guys.
Have a great day.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
This is Courtney.
I love listening to your podcast,
especially the awkward encounters Link has
in his social situations,
but as I was laughing
at the embarrassing things he does,
I realized that I am inclined
to do similar things.
The other day I was at
the store and this mom
was unloading her cart
onto the conveyor belt.
She was at the register and
her four year old daughter
was crying and begging for
her mom to buy her this gum,
and I don't know what
inclined me to be so helpful,
but when her mom was busy
unloading, I made eye contact
with the little kid and I just
shook my head quietly hoping
the little kid would get
the message of, you know,
don't be a brat, like your mom said no,
and I was trying to help out the mom
while she wasn't looking, but
did this stop the little kid?
No, it was just really
awkward as we were looking
at each other and I shook my
head and I told my husband
about this and he was
like, why did you do that?
So I don't know what this inclination is
to do these awkward
things, but I can relate.
Love you guys.
Hey, this is Braden
from Tacoma, Washington.
Just wanted to call and say
that I've been watching you guys
since I was in elementary
school and it's really cool
how much you guys have
grown, and I just really
appreciate that you guys are so open.
The "Ear Biscuits" podcast is
by far my favorite podcast.
it's funny that you guys
always touch on stuff
that I'm like going through
or like, dissecting in
my own life around the
time that I'm doing that.
So it's like, I don't know
man, it feels special.
I know it's not for me, it's for everyone,
but it feels very, very targeted.
So you guys are doing a great job.
Just wanna say thank you
again, Rhett and Link
and all the team over at Good Mythical.
Just keep it up.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.